so I was an actor I was a thespian was
an actor and you had to learn how to
dance and sing to be a child actor I was
a tap dancer and I was in a school in
Long Island New York old legs they're
very creative in Long Island have we
mentioned that have we touched on the
limitless creativity and talent of those
people I think we have well the school
is called legs and I was chosen to be
the boogie-woogie Bugle Boy in the
boogie-woogie Bugle Boy dance number
which is a song the boogie-woogie be
looking over got my name be and I was a
little fat preteen just starting to go
through puberty she starting to get my
newly fat body as my mother said to me
watch because you're a mesomorph you
collect weight in your stomach I'm like
well how about we not eat fast food
every night and watch television could
any could anyone suggest another course
of action thank God for like Joe Rogan
telling people how to be healthy thank
God everything now is about the
celebration of being 700 pounds and on
nine medications like thank God that
there's some there are some people out
there that go maybe that's not the move
okay so we go down there as a dance
troupe I'm the boogie Woogie Bugle Boy I
don't know what you think when you think
you're gonna perform at Disney World you
you probably imagine that there's gonna
be some magical you know big theater or
like it's gonna be at night it's gonna
be well lit there's gonna be a lot of
people that are excited to see you or
whatever um they set up a stage by the
bathrooms and it was in the middle of
the day and it was dog-eat-dog heat
Florida humidity okay and a lot of
people in the dance troupe because they
were from Long Island we're a bit
paunchy even the ladies they were a bit
paunchy okay not all of them but some of
them were you know this wasn't exactly
the top tier this wasn't like winning
the dance competitions this was like the
leftovers okay and so
that trip we stayed at a hotel called
the dolphin and I remember me and a
bunch of fat chicks in boogie Woogie
Bugle Boy outfits these were these were
black tan military outfits and they were
hot and we were sweating through them
even as children we looked like we look
like a regiment of soldiers that the
government would just try out like some
like you know mind control drug on you
know like just the Forgotten platoon of
soldiers that like no one would even go
back for like leave them they're all
dead just say they're dead
you know we'll tell their parents
they're dead you know there was no
Saving Private Ryan for this group tell
you that much if you took a look at us
we're done and we would take a boat from
the dolphin to Disney World every day
and just just just chubby kids sweating
through a tan weird military uniforms
and then we would go to this stage by
the bathrooms and flail around in the
heat and fat tourists would stare at us
while they were on the line for the
bathroom while they were choking down a
churro and they would just stare at us
and we would dance and then afterwards
it was like very little clapping you
know which is so embarrassing very it
was kind of like they were lucky were
like and then we would do it again like
five minutes later that we would keep
doing the same the same number we didn't
have any other number if we keep doing
the same number and they had already
seen it should now like they would look
away now they would like date now no one
even had cell phones so they couldn't
even look at their phone they were just
literally staring at other things
and like we would be performing to
people's backs list so that was a low
point in my life that even Splash
Mountain couldn't fix
Splash Mountain was fun but I remembered
as I was coming down splash around I'm
like oh this is life for most people
it's just drudgery and hell and you get
one moment of weightlessness where water
is sprayed in your face and then they
hand you a picture and they go get the
[ __ ] out and that's what happened to us